any CEO that's hesitating when they know
what they need to do just won't make it
you have to commit on where an
industry's going now you can take steps
to do it you don't have to rush to a
vision obviously but you have to define
the steps and define the steps for your
team welcome to rosetta world our online
community of language learners from
around the globe we drive as a company
very much to vision ultimately this is a
social mission it's about learners
getting to use the language in social
situations from an investor relations
perspective we have chosen to
communicate the reality of what that
vision implies it's not something your
investors always welcome but holding off
on what is going to be you know the
trend is not a strategy because
ultimately it catches up to you and even
let you chat with other learners while
you're doing it the aha we all had when
we were thinking about social and live
and all the possibilities came to us by
virtue of having life experiences of
learning languages looking at how users
were interacting and seeing how new
technology be at video conferencing and
casual gaming might offer us
opportunities from that aha we really
took it to prototyping and trying to
figure out exactly how this would
express itself within our overall
mission as you master more of your new
language often and this is the situation
of rosetta stone the fundamental aha was
right but once we'd released totally
there were a set of issues that came up
but that becomes much more tactical and
we just have to go off and fix a bunch
of things so that the actual roll out in
the real world works smoothly what's
hard is getting the whole team to the
new place and it's much easier to do
that on a visionary basis which language
you won learn